[MUSIC]
One thing's very clear in this data, and
that is firms appreciate two things.
Number one, they appreciate people who
have high ability, shall we say.
People who get high grades, good test
scores, other measures of ability.
The other thing they appreciate is that
you've had some experience in
their industry.
Either because you learned something or
the thing we're focusing on is that you've
reduced the uncertainty as to whether or
not you'd be a good fit in their industry.
[MUSIC]
If you've never worked in the industry
that I'm hiring you to work in before,
we don't know how well you're gonna fit
there.
So when I got hired into academia, they
already knew I would fit that pretty
well because I'd been a grad student and
I'd been in school a long time.
But they didn't know it for sure and so
over a period of time you figure out, hey,
this person can do research and can teach
and things like that.
It's that type of thing, and the more we
see that you've had experience doing that,
the better sense we have that you will fit
in our industry.
[MUSIC]
Let's consider two applicants for a job.
They're both second year MBAs applying for
full-time jobs at the same company.
Holding everything else equal,
if one of those candidates has worked in
that industry before.
Their odds of getting that job are more
than double
that of the person who's never worked in
that industry.
In fact, they're about 2.4 times as high.
So just taking, you know, as a, as a
baseline.
Suppose there's a company which accepts
10% of its
applicants that have never worked in the
industry before.
That same company would accept, would make
offers to about
24% of the people who have worked in that
industry before.
So you can see that it's quite a dramatic
difference,
it's more than twice as likely to get the
job.
[MUSIC]
There's a very natural rent to own, if you
will,
arrangement for MBA's, which is called the
summer internship.
And it's extremely useful for testing the
waters.
So an MBA who says, I'd really like to
work in
investment banking, but they've never
really worked in banking.
They can, by going to work in banking over
the summer, they solve two problems.
One, they find out whether or not they
like working in banking.
And the other is,
a bank might be very reluctant to hire
somebody who's never worked in investment
banking if they're gonna have to go
through a lot of effort to fire them.
They fire them naturally at the end of a
summer internship.
There's a nice, natural breaking point in
the employment relationship.
Now, a lot of those people get offers to
come back, and
that's very helpful in terms of making the
market work smoothly.
But if it didn't work out for some reason,
the firm isn't stuck with
a person it doesn't want, which can be
very disruptive and expensive.
[MUSIC]
You see that same thing where certainty,
with,
where knowing that the person has
experience is valuable to that employer.
But it's not quite as valuable because
they're more willing to take a chance on
the outsider, because at the end of the
summer they can get rid of them for free.
So in that, in, in the example there, if
we have two applicants to
a similar firm for summer internships,
the, the person with
experience in that industry is about 1.8
times as likely to get the job offer.
Whereas if it were a full time job, it's
well over two times, closer to 2.4 times.
[MUSIC]
We see a lot of people who get summer
internships get an offer to go back and
work there, in our data it's about half.
Now a lot of the people who don't get
offers to come back that's for
budgetary reasons.
They go to a small company that turns out
to not have
the ability to hire the person back or
something like that.
But a lot of it, if you look at companies
that have large numbers of summer interns,
they're making offers to maybe most of
them, but far from all of them.
So firms and students are able to take
advantage of what they learned
about each other over the summer to get
the better matches.
The summer is very useful, both for
learning about firms,
learning about industries, learning about
each other and so forth.
We see a lot of firms make offers to the
people that work there over the summer.
We see a lot of students go back to those
firms, but a lot choose not to.
So both sides of the market are learning
something, both about
the match they have with that firm and how
that compares to their outside options.
That they then can go compare that they
then can go look at over the next
recruiting season.
[MUSIC]
The time to take a chance is in the
summer.
People will take a chance on you in your
summer internships much
more than they will in full time jobs.
And you see more and more, at least
Stanford students,
I don't know about other business schools
as much, taking,
trying to split their time between two
internships over the summer.
And especially if you want to try
something new,
that's a great idea, as long as each of
those internships is long enough for
you to learn whether or not this is the
right place for you.
So if, if a five week internship is just
enough time to, you know,
learn where your desk is, and you don't
really get a great feel for the industry,
then that's not gonna solve the problem.
But if five weeks or six weeks, or however
long a split internship is,
is long enough to really learn about that
industry, and that business,
then splitting your summer up gives, gives
you so many more options going forward.
And so much more information going
forward.
[MUSIC]